[Applause]
the threats are growing
and the threats are changing in the
biggest review since the cold war
we now know how the british armed forces
will take them on
in defence it is too tempting to use the
shield of sentimentality
to protect previous battle-winning but
now outdated capabilities
to release some money the size of the
army will be cut to 72.5 000 soldiers
the smallest it has been since 1714 and
the war
of spanish succession but millions will
be invested in new technology
including small surveillance drones and
communications equipment
we have to break out of thinking about
an army as only being about the number
of people that are in it
it's a function of the people their
quality their training their equipment
their stocks and their ally
[Music]
the entire fleet of c-130 hercules
aircraft
will be retired by 2023 as will nine
chinook helicopters
and 20 puma helicopters they won't be
replaced
it is bad news for the military's
ability to lift equipment
and troops around the world i very much
doubt that there's something that an
army of seventy two thousand five
hundred
augmented by a productive reserve of
thirty thousand
working in partnership with allies
wouldn't be able to deal with
the mod has already bought 48 f-35
jets and says that it will buy more but
they haven't specified
how many more it won't be the 138
the uk originally committed to buying
though
instead two billion pounds will be
invested in developing the jets of the
future
[Music]
much of this money will directly benefit
british industry
this review like any review i guess is a
case of
give and take the headlines will
naturally focus on the shrinking size of
the army
but in truth in fairness there are some
areas of quite
revolutionary investment and the defense
chiefs and the politicians have insisted
that they've taken decisions based on
threats not based on finances
nevertheless if it's going to work it's
going to take
quite a radical cultural change
in the ministry of defence
get it right and the british armed
forces could be a very different
very nimble outfit but get it wrong and
they'll not only be smaller
but also weaker alastair bunker sky news